and before we go here's one thing you
can do today to live a happier healthier
and more productive life it's part of
our partnership with Gretchen Rubin and
her award-winning podcast happier with
so many of us stuck at home Gretchen
joins us with some tips on how we can
invest in our professional futures
Gretchen good morning so I mean if
you're inside you're not going to the
office maybe you don't even have a job
anymore how can you take steps to
improve your likelihood of having a job
or thriving in the future
one thing you want to do is you want to
present yourself you know with as much
strength as possible so this is a time
to update your resume update your
LinkedIn profile if you have bio on a
company website or your own website if
you need to draft a cover letter this is
the time to think about all your
responsibilities strengths achievements
so you can put your best foot forward
you also say now it's not a bad time to
consider a lifestyle change what do you
mean well for some people there's so
much uncertainty it might be helpful to
think about do I need to get a roommate
should I think about moving back home
should I move to a less expensive city
or neighborhood it can be very daunting
to think about these big changes but now
is the time where you could start
thinking about what that might mean for
you so Gretchen real quick what is one
thing you can do to create a more
productive space at home from which to
do all this extra work well we're all
working at home so one thing is to clear
out all the the files clear out the
shelves try to make more space for
yourself tackle those projects that
you've been putting off and sometimes
you can discover new space that you
could use like maybe you can have a
phone booth made out of a storage closet
and you can create a place if you're
doing a lot of video chats where maybe
you're more set up to look professional
and again put your best foot forward all
right all really good advice Gretchen we
can all be really productive if we put
our minds to it thanks so much